you have met Vladimir Putin you know
that economy very well rumors of its
collapse were greatly exaggerated
what what failed to happen well I think
one that Russia is lot more resilient it
is the fifth or sixth largest country in
the world so it is not comparable to an
Iran or Syria for instance in terms of
US or Western European sanctions that's
the first big difference the second is
that Russia started 2014 Brendon with
about five hundred and thirty billion
dollars worth of reserves now they have
about three hundred and ten it is still
substantial and the officials in Moscow
told me that they were prepared to deal
with sanctions continuing into 27g yep
if I could just come in with some data
real GDP in the last quarter minus two
point two percent and CPI 15.8% ordinary
average Russians aren't feeling what
you're saying are they no they are
feeling the pain it's clear that the
situation is very difficult and I came
from my last visit in February Bonnie I
came away my forecast is actually worse
than the consensus I'm looking for minus
five percent for 2015 the consensus is
probably more around minus three so
clearly the the price in the inflation
in prices the fall in real wages which
is starting to take place right is
helping what is helping is that the
brushin population is declining from 149
million to one hundred and forty three
hundred and forty four million so that
in turn means my working age population
is reduced and the real wages don't drop
as much as what the inflation because so
there's the economic background the
reality is mr. Putin is going to speak
and then he's going to speak with
Charlie Rose we wanted to figure out
exactly what's going to set what he's
going to say and what we should listen
for Robert Kaplan with us from HBS if
mr. Putin was a case study in HBS what
would you emphasize that we should
listen for this morning is which
audience is he speaking to so this is a
very which is important for any CEO well
it's particularly important if you are
if you're running Russia and you have
the degree of control that he has he's
dealing
very very difficult economic times
domestically it's tough for businesses
to raise capital the rubles declining
that they can they can gut they can hide
some of these impacts for a while he's
not a general ero domestic he's very
mystic his first audience I believe is
always the domestic audience because
he's got to retain control and because
he has such tight control that's the
reason he's able to manage this
and he needs to to some extent put
position Russia's a little bit of a
victim yeah a little bit us-versus-them
and that appeals to so yes the popular
discussion on Ukraine may be on the
southern the broader southern border
he's going to talk he's going to talk
why what's going on
what's happened to them is unfair and
how Western powers are treating them
unfairly Brendon do you bring in NATO on
that you think that mr. rose will bring
up NATO with mr. Putin I mean that's
hard to say we have been hearing from
Russian officials for the last four days
just how unconscionable this act of
bringing in tanks to Poland it's a
needless provocation we have heard that
language I would expect him to say
something about it I want to ask about
the event itself Robert Kaplan Tom and I
were talking to the break about how it
clearly wants to be a Davos and you go
to these events I've been to one in
Korea they're all over they say we want
to be the Davos of X are these just for
the egos of the leaders of those
countries or do they provide a actual
valuable forum well you've got to
remember when this conference was
started it was with higher oil prices it
was pre Ukraine pre sanctions and it
actually made some sense that they might
be emerging leader among growing
economies Rick the the sanctions Ukraine
has sort of taken the air out of this
and that's why this conference seems a
little odd ernow than a might of five
years ago I want to talk a little bit
about not getting is about getting the
gas out of Russia this is a constant
problem Russia has been working with
Germany to get the Nord Stream pipeline
on line and now of course they're in
discussions with Greece you know and
this bears on what we're talking about
what is the Russian economy look like is
this is this politics or is this
economics when they talk to Greece about
this Turkish stream pipeline I think it
is partly politics partly economic
Brenden on the political side clearly if
Greece were to join with the with Russia
and say that sanctions should not be
extended when they expire in about a
month's time that would be a big victory
for Russia I don't think it's going to
happen that's one of the hopes that the
Russians have it's very much on the
political side on the economic side
despite the drop in reserves and the
problem that Russia is having with lower
oil prices they still have a substantial
amount of foreign exchange reserves when
you compare with the crises of 1998 and
2009 and they have the ability to help
Greece the point here is I don't think
they will come to the assistance of
Greece now just for Greece to turn
around and give that money to the IMF or
the European Union right once it is a
default and you actually need new money
to purchase medicines for Greeks for
instance that's when the Russian money
becomes important speaker Mar thank you
so much greatly appreciate this with a
sreekumar global economics